[Music]
[Music]
hello YouTube just Louis in my friends
this is guns on here welcome to the
second episode of my attacking chess
gambit where we are going to look at
very aggressive and tricky charlie
gambit against evil which you might use
as a complete surprise weapon in the
tournament practice the opening arises
after the following model d4 ePHI and
now by force if white has to keep his
advantage then he has to take on e5
white can try all the moves but it does
not prove anything critical as after
defy black and simply respond with
Bishop to c5 and it's black who is
already ahead in terms of peace
development where if you compare with
Knight to f3 which is even versed in
this position as after E for attacking
the knight doesn't matter wherever this
Knight goes after defy I think it is
black is detecting the game with the
space in the center of the border so all
in all considering all these facts here
white has to take on e5
and after that the Charlie gambit
springs to the life with the MU d6 at
this point white has two options whether
to take the second pawn or completely
declined it with either the move Bishop
to f4 or Knight to f3 let's first look
at what happens if white accept the
second pawn with he captures d6 which in
fact more of only played from this
position and now you see the point
behind sacrifice upon as black get this
free piece development and if anytime
white commits himself with the movie 4
then this position will be directly
transposed into the aliping black band
gambit which I have already covered
in the first part so if you haven't
check it out I do recommend you my first
part where I have recommend same kind of
set up against the movie for now once
again I want to stress to important
point number one
there is hardly any theory in this
opening that means you and your opponent
are thrown to their own resources just
in the opening and the second and most
important point you have to remember
just like our afore lecture the oral aim
of the black camp is to castle on
opposite side and then launch
devastation to the white king which
clearly compensate the deficit of extra
pawn now to illustrate the power of this
position I like to demonstrate a model
game between two mm plus rated opponent
which will not only give you a clear
path how black should continue but it
also highlight the important attacking
and tactical ideas black and launch
against white camp in the game
white continue with Knight to f3 and
obviously black respond with Bishop to
g4 and again if white play the movie 4
then it will transpose to the e4 gambit
so in this game whitey need continue
with III not allowing black to give him
a double bond okay now both decide
complete their piece development
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 Knight to c6
and Bishop to e2 planning to castle on
the Kings side so accordingly black
played this obvious response 27 clearing
the path on the Queen side and that rook
on aid is eagerly coming on d8 with
pressure on the White Queen
well why doesn't like him so he blocked
the part with Bishop to d2 and after the
indeed castle on the Queen side he
figured out that if he prematurely
castle on the King side then his King
can come in a severe danger with blacks
immediate attack so in the game who I
thought that okay I'm a pawn up why not
exchange some pieces with Knight to d4
so that way I can neutralize the black
ongoing pressure here comes the first
critical moment guys I want you to pause
this video and find out how you're going
to respond at this position
well congratulations if you find night
captures d4 which is in fact the best
move in this position the point is after
Bishop captures g4 and King to be eight
black has created the first threat of
the game namely Knight captures g4 and
then deliver for concie to something
which white has to respond immediately
okay why decided to play Bishop we do
unpinning the e3 pawn so now indeed
white is threatening of an ID and wisely
so black put the knight on a lovely a
six squared now as the light square
Bishop has been exchanged white feel
quite safe on the Kings side so he
indeed castle now but the important
point is he's seriously missing out his
knight on f3 which was the guardian of -
two squared and that is the thematic
loophole black walk on throughout the
game now comes the second critical
movement guys you know where White King
is what will be your next move where I
hope you do find this accurate move h5
and as you can see black has a very
simple plan to execute namely Knight to
g4 and then Queen to h5 and then a
launch devastation on the White King
which is not safely placed on the g1
Square for a time being white doesn't
bother about all this and he continued
with Bishop to f3 putting that Bishop on
a lovely diagonal but in fact this move
was the first mistake of the white camp
here comes the first star mu and before
I move on I like you to pause this video
and find out that golden boy did you
find it
let's see have you seen this deciding
blow Oh
ha ha ha so suddenly Bishop - - comes
into the picture which was not at all
expected by white camp and I think you
should always look out for such a
sacrifices when you play this aggressive
gambit guess what white can take it why
what happens if we take well here comes
the simple answer Knight to g4 and white
King is completely busted he can't play
King to g3 as Queen to d6 leads to the
checkmate and the same goes for the King
to h3 as after Knight to g5 white King
will be completely humiliated so
accordingly White has two options
number one Bishop captures g4 and I hope
everybody here knows this pattern very
well as after H caps as g4 discs of a
check and when white King goes to the
Jeevan yup you got it Queen to h4 a
complete destruction on that file and
the only hope which is to move the F
born completely fails due to the simple
move g3 and white King is completely
boxed in
last but not least King 2g1 doesn't
provide any good solutions as after
Quint wedge for the checkmate threat is
there and if white continue with rook to
even then after Queen captures f2 check
King to h1 and now winning blue rook
captures g2 not only hitting the Queen
but if white try to save the queen
then Queen to h4 leads to the checkmate
so no wonder after long thought who I
decided not to take the bishop and
continue with King to h1 okay black says
I have done my work sweetie I have
regained the pawn back and now I'm
simply going to retrieve two the more
attacking square with Bishop to e5 and
you can see the spin is so annoying that
in the game white says enough is enough
I want to play Quint we to remove this
tension but this is the case where you
are coming out from the frying pan
straight into the fire the fourth
critical and in fact winning more of the
game has been played here which
completely stunned the white opponent
can you find it out
to be honest there are a lot of good
moves over here but I think black find
the best killing move in this position
are you ready
rook captures D too bad
what a move and you know what white
can't even touch that rock the point is
if you foolishly take this rook then
after Knight to e4 black is threatening
to think number one he's attacking the
Queen and the number two but the very
obvious threat is Queen to h4 and
checkmate the white king
so unfortunately white has to give up
the Queen and in fact the game in the
game white see that immediately so he
decided to play the Queen to be Phi
threatening a checkmate on b7 but this
can be easily dealt with Knight to d8
defending a beginners threat now comes
the final mistake of the game white
played rook a to Devon challenging the
dangerous rook sitting on the second
rank but what he all looked is after c6
go into a for the deciding winning move
by the black camp last time guys I want
you to pause this video and find out the
winning sequence from the black camp
okay I'm really sure that you have find
out this winning move Knight to g4 and
how you going to stop Queen to h4 and
chat meeting to White King well it has
the only option g3 but you know now what
is going to happen
yup the another dazzling sacrifice
Bishop captures g3 and after this
however white plays his King is not
going to survive for a long time the
game finished very quickly white indeed
place F captures g3 but after rook to h2
check King to Jeevan and now the
simplest move in the world Queen
captures e3 which leads to checkmate in
Toulouse
wow what an attacking and entertaining
game which clearly highlights how one
should play this gambit and what sort of
fun black get against the move d4
now before we leave it is very important
to understand what happens if white
doesn't take the second pawn and try to
hang on with moves such as Knight to f3
or Bishop to f4 the first move I want to
consider is Bishop to f4 which as per my
opinion probably the most critical line
from the white camp and against this my
recommendation is you should continue
with Knight to c6 pressurizing the e5
pawn if Knight to f3 then Bishop to g4
and the position will be transposed into
the knight to f3 variation which we are
going to see after this so the most
critical response here is to capture on
d6 and White's idea is very simple he
wants to give us
a week backward pawn on d6 which you
have to avoid at any cost so that is why
it is very important for you to remember
that in this position you have this
tactical idea
quint web six counter-attacking white
two soft spots now if we open and
continue with Quintus even defending
both the sports then after Bishop takes
c6 Bishop takes d6 and the move Queen
captures d6 we achieve we want to do
leading development and aim to castle on
the opposite side so that's not an issue
but the critical move is when white play
the move III and invite us to take on b2
which I doubt any of your opponent will
do it over the board anyways after this
my recommendation is you should
certainly grab on b2 and the sample line
can draw like this
Knight to d2 defending the rook now we
are going to take on d6 and after Bishop
takes d6 pawn takes d6 rook to b1 and
the move Queen to e5 yes indeed Black
has a weak isolated pawn on the d6 but
the good points are Black has gained his
pawn back and not to forget it as a
counterpart white also has these two
weaknesses
and as I have highlighted over here once
your major piece are lining up on the C
file then sooner or later C pawn will be
dropping of the border last but not
least the second most popular choice in
these positions are night we have three
defending on e5 and not grabbing the
second pawn and so far if you're looking
at my lectures I don't think so you have
any trouble to finding out blacks next
move which is very obvious
yup Bishop to g4 getting rid of the
knife and then taking you pawn back
White has two ways to hang on to this
pawn and let's see each bite on the
first move Bishop to g5 is not at all
Gould and now you will see the benefit
of playing the move Bishop to g4 as we
can simply continue with Queen to d7 and
as of now Queen is well protected Black
is indeed threatening to capture on e5
so that forces Y to capture on d6 and
after Bishop captures d6 I think we have
achieved what we want to do and on top
white Bishop is completely misplaced as
black and get a tempo with either the
move f6 or at 6:00 and then g5 which
gives him tremendous fast attacking
prospects on the White King side so even
though Bishop to g4 has been recommended
in some books this is not a great idea
by the white camp
finally let's check out what is
happening after the move Bishop to a
fool
keep pressurizing the d6 square but
against this we already know what to do
yup putting pressure on e5 with Knight
to c6 and when why take on d6 do you
remember yup this sematic
counter-attacking tactic Queen to f6 and
again
Queen to c1 can be successfully met with
Bishop captures d6
so the only critical response here is
III and this time around as our Bishop
has been developed to the g4 square
taking on b2 is not advisable as b7 is
also weak so accordingly my suggestion
here is you should take on d6 and after
Bishop captures d6 play this powerful
move castle on the Queen side and once
we take up a piece back not only black
can generate tremendous piece activity
with attack but this position is already
looking quite scary for the white camp
so more or less this is also response
against all the sideline moves where
white doesn't accept the second-born
that's it guys I hope with this lecture
now you are confident enough to play the
charlyk gambit and surprise a lot of
your opponent with his attacking stuff
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and
I'll meet you my next episode very soon
bye and take care